- On this episode, I talk
about my course in college,
snowball fights,
and
how you become viral with no cash.
(energetic music)
You ask questions, and I answer them.
This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
What's up everybody?
This is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and you're watching the #AskGaryVee Show
Episode Number 63.
It is snowing insane outside
and it hasn't even started.
Blizzard 2015 is here
and the weather has completely
screwed up my Tuesday,
as you can imagine,
so I'm gonna sneak this in real quick
and answer one or two questions today,
so a tight show for episode 63,
but that's the way it is.
- [Voiceover] Chris asks, "What
surprises or interests you
"about brands with High Brand Equity,
"but don't have huge budgets?"
- Chris, this is a great question.
That was a lovely Instagram photo.
This whole Instagram
thing is gonna be awesome.
As a matter of fact, you know what?
I almost didn't do this episode,
so DRock, I know you're disappointed
with only two questions,
but that's better than zero
and you've heard that before.
You like that? You like that, Staphon?
So, that actually gives me a second here
to push the VaynerNation
'cause I know we went out
super late the other night.
Instagram photos, Instagram questions,
let's link up how you do that,
let's get on that for
the rest of the week.
Chris, it's a great question.
You know, look, this is
why I love social media.
I believe that social
media is the plumbing
to word of mouth in our society
and I think there's a lot of brands
that don't spend marketing
that just win on having a great product.
If you make a great product
and you get people to taste
it, physically and literally,
meaning try your app,
check out your store,
wear your hoody, or actually
try sauce and it's delicious,
word of mouth will kick in.
I think the world we live in now,
it actually speeds that up
because when somebody had that sauce,
now they take a photo
and put on Instagram,
be like, "This is delicious."
That's a lot better than 1997
where, like, I had this sauce
and then, like, Staphon and
I are playing basketball,
we go, "By the way, the sauce,"
like, what? I did that once?
Like, I think it was impossible to amplify
the way we are now on an
individual person level,
so I actually think the era of companies
with very limited or zero
marketing budgets is here
and I do think social
media is that foundation.
So, what interests me is that
this is the greatest time ever
to not have a marketing budget
in a world as a marketer
because so much of it can
be organic and authentic.
It's hard, you have to be great,
and most of all, your product
has to be sensational.
So I think the brands that will break out,
the products that will break
out in the next half decade
with zero dollars are gonna be anomalies,
but that's predicated on them
actually making a phenomenal product.
- [Voiceover] BlueArcher
ask, "If you could create
"or teach your own college
or high school course,
"what would the name of the class be
"and how would you teach it?"
- (laughs)
This is a great question.
First of all, this is really fun,
like I thought all the Instagram photos
are just gonna be somebody
holding up a sign,
like the rules,
I didn't realize so many people,
like that little jab
on the rules, I didn't,
by the way, VaynerNation, you
are not following the rules,
like the whole, like, sign
thing is not happening,
but let's do it one more time.
Here's how you get your answer,
but obviously 'cause some of you
are getting through with
your non-following the rules,
the answer is you guys are
all gonna continue to do this,
but the whole, like,
imposing me into the photo
is phenomenal, didn't see that coming.
Good job with you guys.
My course would be called (laughs)
Oh my god, this is such a funny thing.
I mean, my course would
literally be called
"Why You Shouldn't Have Signed Up
"for this Course in the First Place,
"taught by Gary Vaynerchuk."
and it would talk about the disconnect
between where school is
and where the real world is right now,
how, I would try to
teach, more than anything,
for people not to take my words
and try to regurgitate them.
And look, it's almost what I'm trying,
I mean, I'm teaching my course
right now with #AskGaryVee.
My big thing here, guys, is,
and I raz the VaynerNation
once in a while,
so in this short episode,
it feels appropriate.
Way too many of you are just
regurgitating what I'm saying
instead of actually doing it.
Boy, do I love all of you that
hearted up my Hustle picture
on Instagram the other day.
Let's put that up.
And then when I looked at,
like, seven or eight people,
they just see how they were hustling
'cause I keep doing it, I keep,
VaynerNation, understand one thing.
I take enormous pride in
double checking your actions
while you regurgitate my hyperbole.
Let me tell you why.
It's not 'cause I'm the best dude ever.
It's because if my fans that spew my stuff
aren't actually acting
on my recommendation,
which is putting in the
work, doing the right things,
listening to their audience,
working, hustling, trying,
doing the right practices, not automating,
well then, when people,
like, if you post a photo,
regram it, and like, hustle,
but you're playing Call of Duty all day,
then all your friends on Instagram,
the 97 people are like,
"Well, that's just a guy
"that spews hyperbole because
if you love him so much
"but you aren't doing it,
"well then, that just disconnects."
So, one of the main reasons
I'm paying attention
to what everybody is doing
is because if the people
that are consuming my content
and retweeting and pushing out my stuff
are not acting on that behavior,
that has a chance of hurting me.
You know how fun it's been over
the last four or five months
'cause of the show because
of the zinging that you,
many of the people that have
commented on every episode
have emailed me and said, "You know what?
"I haven't actually been doing it,"
like, I'm talking the talk,
but I'm not walking the walk.
That's been really fun
for me to watch, and so,
I forgot the question.
Oh, it's the course, right?
(laughs)
I mean, look, the course would be,
like, listen to everything
I'm gonna tell you
about the disconnect between
school and the real world
from a marketing business standpoint.
I know you could be a lawyer or a doctor,
you need to learn that
stuff, I respect that,
but from like entrepreneur business stuff
and the whole course
would be eight to 12 weeks
of me pounding you not to
regurgitate my information,
but to act on it.
Over here, I'm over here now DRock.
You need to act on it.
You need to actually execute.
You can't say hustle and then not hustle.
You can't say, and this is the,
the hustle part, a lot of you are doing.
Here's the part that really pisses me off.
All of you that retweeted
my whole listen to people
instead of just talk, you
need to engage, right?
And the other thing is a lot of you
are engaging with each
other, which is great.
I love that, like, 20 of you
become really good friends
and retweet each other
and heart everything,
but go out there and use
search on Twitter, right?
Try different things.
Go write articles on Medium.
I can't believe how many of you
who are not writing articles on Medium,
the one platform that rewards virality
to people that have no audience,
the far majority of
you, you should be what?
We're hustling Medium every day
and I have awareness
because it's giving me
more free awareness.
Guys, Medium is a platform
that allows you if you write a good story
for one of their editors
to put on the home page
and all of a sudden, you got a platform
and a couple of you have done
it, and we've pounded here,
and you see me doing it.
That's the part that pisses me off.
You see me doing it heavy.
Plenty of you have asked the,
"Hey, AskGaryVee, why
do you post up on Medium
"and not your own blog?"
Because it brings me,
just so everybody understands,
I will never do anything
if it doesn't bring me
either short-term or long-term value,
so if I'm doing it, don't you think
you should be paying attention
a little more, the why.
And so, my course would be very,
(chuckle) bring you back.
My course will be very predicated on:
Here's all the advice, but
please don't be a student.
Be a practitioner.
Question of the Day.
I wanna hear the story
of your favorite all-time snow day.
Mine?
Me and my sister were
having a snowball fight
and we literally got into a rhythm.
We both have, like, little bunkers.
I throw it, she duck.
She throw it, I duck.
And then about four, five
in, I figured out the timing.
So I made two and I threw one,
but then I got really ready again
and as soon as she came up, I threw it,
and hit her directly in the mouth
and she bled all over the place
and AJ thought it was funny
'cause he was only three.
You keep asking questions.
I'll keep answering.
I mean, it's gonna be,
like, what the (bleep)
- [Voiceover] That, like, escalated.
- [Gary] On this episode, I
talk about my course in college,
snowball fights.
(energetic music)